[Music]
[Music]
all right by the Ruth young back on a
playground hey you know I just didn't
you know things that I did in my past
man you know it uh you know when they
say your past come back to haunt you a
lot of things that I did man it could
fix me like today you know it steers me
in the wrong places you know it's good
that I got God that pulled me back out
you know I learned at a young age that I
can banging [ __ ] I liked it you know but
all I was doing was killing you know my
bucks you know and I'm not just meaning
skin color but yeah I was just killing
my brothers and at some point I do mean
skin colors because you have to look
that way as well and first indeed you
know everybody want to be with the
business and play these old tub con
games man you know I know tough-guy just
I'm just me I get it with anybody I mean
anybody win lose or draw you know you
don't kill me and we go here too but
that's nonsense
kids don't like to go to lock you up you
know kids you know my kids and I start
off young gay man I thought it was my
job to make the Bloods and the Crips
even I really pursued it like that
people that know they know that keep got
injured you know I'm not proud about it
it's nothing to brag about
I feel bad about it you don't feel
guilty about it because I said I got
older 52 years old now you know I
realized that's not it that's not the
way you know I feel bad when I look back
you know the decisions that I made
yeah yeah I'm gonna treasures again you
know I've been on top of the game island
beam up but of the game and I've been on
the side of the game I'm back a bun in
the game those books out there TV man
looking on don't even think about it bro
I'm with this [ __ ] but I yeah man I just
want to stretch that back cause you know
everybody get on here nature lolly did
they bashed up you know and I got a lot
of bad stuff you know but I thought that
I would highlight where I went wrong as
to where some of the other people could
see where you might be headed I would
say roll because yeah I know it's the
thousand foot cliff down there you
coming that way like hey dude turn
around
it's a thousand four click down here
don't go that way and you keep going I
want y'all to stop me but I left that
show destiny then you know my gosh but
you know I'm gonna try to stop you in at
the same time stay to the right road and
that's where I'm on the day you know I
got on and I talked about my past and
and it looked like I was glorifying the
virus and all that but I don't really
grew up I'm more of a peaceful manner
damn humble God got me going through
some trials it's to make me strong I
know everyone put too much on you but
it's tough man it's tough man it's like
me against the world I really feel like
that Pakistan but at the same time I'm
giving a [ __ ] banging on if that's what
it is you know I still got to be meeting
everybody hey man be careful be get that
[ __ ] on I want to be dangerous I keep my
[ __ ] boy they know you dangerous
hangover a bunkie don't rise this is the
Upstate dangerous man
and I just want to appeal to everybody
you know all the races man I mean Chris
was about to be upon us you know someone
up celebration I mean bring some pieces
of the ship with at least someone back
up up off the streets man
doing people wrong and all that unless
his have some peaceful miss Baker [ __ ]
a set of record in California have some
[ __ ] peace school some peace that's a
mom a holiday spirit man you know both
stop hurting each other doing all the
stuff that don't nobody want done in
them I mean you do it to somebody but
you don't want it done done you do that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] I mean another thing
I want to get past was that God is the
one true Living God people have many
beliefs but your belief compliment
what God chose okay we've got other guys
that show some things I did that with
any my god
but God showed me and there is a guy and
don't leave all the nonsense man may
have a fight but one thing that got
straight there is a higher being and
that being will guide you and will
protect you that's Scripture so I walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death I shall fear that's the key to
that I shall fear no evil
if you start feeling you know that guy
go he walked through that valley you
gonna get knocked down but I shall not
fear that's the key God say don't fear
so guy say I know this dude he said
don't feel I'm going to tell my chest I
might go [ __ ] you [ __ ] - will you
ain't gonna get Aryan but I mean she did
come on man you know I know dude
yesterday get him at County Jail would
think that that scripture that said the
trooper said you're free you going in
courtroom and telling judge everything
you did and get like that's not what
that mean that means the truth will set
you free from the bondages of scene
which is on a spiritual level not mature
so quick give me your lives away like
that I just want one thing man Merry
Christmas Happy New Year's I had a good
Thanksgiving ain't had one in a while
yeah I'm still I'm tough me loud I'm
sitting in my man got me on I'm back on
I might write a rap next week my man
have me on my coach saying